filing Shrine is a rather terrible place
when you think about it
sure the fire keeper will always be
there for you but what about when you're
not there for her
she's disposable forgotten just like
Champion gundir who's stranded in
another dimension
or like the handmaiden chained to this
fate for what must feel like an eternity
remember well I am Undead
bound Forever by the shrine's curse
as the fire is linked over and over
kingdoms change and so too does the
Shrine in this world as we know the
shrine is a literal graveyard of Ash
quite the fitting of an exhausted World
though one constant through it all is
the suffering of the fire Keepers these
women aren't as selfless as you might
think
they're prisoners just like you and they
fight for the linking of the fire for
with the linking of the fire comes rest
finally the curse of the undead will be
lifted
and I can die human
long have I awaited one such as you
one who can set me free
Ashen one link the fire
for the Lord of Cinder for the Ashen
prisoners for all those held to preserve
the fire
link the first Flame
though as we've come to learn this rest
is temporary and the curse never was
lifted and yet the legend of the linking
of the fire continues to infect the
minds of many Undead are shepherded
towards the first flame and the kingdoms
of the gods are always designed to
enable their sacrifice in some way have
you ever noticed that the incinerating
Kiln is never too far from the kingdom
of men filing Shrine is a crumbled peak
of New Londo
Throne of want sits below Drang Lake
Castle
and in lothric hidden behind the King's
Garden along a trail of Ash and untended
Graves is the current iteration of
Firelink Shrine and what must be the
thousandth fire keeper capable of
sending us forward to be face to face
with cinder itself
to the true air let him Grant death
to the old gods of lordran
deliverers of the first flame those that
failed to become Cinder are cremated all
the same their ashes scattered in the
untended graves by the soul of Cinder
those that succeed become Lords of
Cinder but it says a lot about the
future that they fight for if our Lords
have refused to fight for it a second
time and so the grand betrayal was
conceived this betrayal of the flame was
not a novel concept by any means but
perhaps it was still a necessary one
considering it led to the link of fire
being threatened and at the Bell tolling
for the unkindled
according to his Cinders the prince
lothric was destined to be a lord of
Cinder and was cherished by the royal
family though ironically he was born ill
shriveled and frail unable even to wield
the Platinum sword that was his
Birthright conversely lothric's older
brother lorian was a great champion of
the realm while his younger brother's
sword would never be wielded his was
scorched Black by the flame of the demon
Prince which he had slain
single-handedly the great tragedy that's
referenced so often in their law is
surely that while Prince lothric was
chosen to be a lord of Cinder Prince
lorian was the one suited for it
so Lorien must have had a great love for
his brother for he embraced lothric's
curse merging their two Souls
tragically this left lorian mute and
crippled yet it is said that lorian
indeed wished it so all the same there's
this great mention of the grief of the
twin princes for once they came together
they rejected everything that had made
this sacrifice necessary so instead of
linking the flame they settled in their
throne room and simply watched the fire
fade from a distance and with their
strength combined fought off any who
would seek their Cinders ill starred are
they who take the throne I shall not
stand among them
the fire linking curse the legacy of
Lords
let it all fade into nothing
you remain
among the accursed
if we were to join them in their rest
this is the faith that the princes would
have us live a darkened Shrine most
likely their Shrine is hidden behind the
chambers of the consumed King
and items tell us that if a place is
devoid of light so too will it be devoid
of time perhaps this explains away the
terrible convolution within this place
justifying how those in the future
Shrine can be pulled to this realm like
the swordmaster justifying how we
physically walk here from present day
lothric and accounting for the dead fire
keeper who is from the past and tucked
away but of all the things here from
past present or future she is the most
consequential for she is the one that's
holding the eyes that enable a fire
keeper to betray the flame ah found her
did we
the black eyes that Shimmer within I see
it is as if it were but yesterday
we did all we could to spare her from
them
much has happened since
may happen I should apprise thee of what
the thin light of these eyes might
reveal to the eyeless fire keeper
scene of betrayal
things never intended for her Ken
visions of
this Ages end
the eyes are said to have belonged to
the first fire keeper and of all the
would-be Lords of Cinder it makes the
most sense for Prince lothric to have
had access to such an heirloom he is
after all the descendant of old royalty
inheritor of the throne and it seems
that he and lorian coaxed their fire
keeper to stifle the flame back in their
age much like we can with the eyes in
our possession
now ask yourself how does little F know
about any of this ludleth refers to the
eyes and the woman they're planted upon
in the past tense it follows that
somehow he linked the flame after the
princes refused to
look not in bewilderment as I say
I linked the fire long ago becoming the
Lord of Simba
if substantiation be thy want
set thine eyes upon my childhood course
this sad cadaver there's something wrong
in this dialogue listen to how guilty
and how defensive he sounds a true Lord
of Cinder would have no need to
constantly reaffirm his or her
legitimacy
and we get closer to the truth on this
by listening to him as he sleeps as he
dreams about the nightmarish right of
linking the fire ah
the bone
[Music]
be done with me
no God no
I cannot bear it
birds birds help me
I am a lord
are we flame but like
shoulder the world
forgive me
I'm not playing
I'm not from his half burnt corpse to
the guilt that we hear it seems most
likely that ludleth partially linked the
flame perhaps it's because of him that
there's a light in this world at all
that the Bell was able to toll for help
truly though this story is one that I
can't possibly claim to have all the
answers to for example was it possible
for weak little little left to link the
fire because the twin princes had
already defeated the soul of Cinder if
ludleth could link it why couldn't
champion gundir who was the first fire
keeper why are there black knights here
and why is this place still so dangerous
to our unkindled perhaps this place was
laid with Defenders for a reason for of
all the shrines this one seems the most
geared towards stopping anyone who would
dare rise and somehow link the fire it's
difficult and perhaps pointless to come
through here Champion gundir did arrive
only to find the coiled sword of the
shrine broken in advance
the fire keeper gone grave wardens
Patrol the graves are devoted to
hemorrhaging any reanimating corpses and
the only fire keeper that patrols the
grounds is a scholar the daughter of
crystal is drawn to any Embers that
would walk through this Shrine and of
all the things that don't make sense in
this story it does make a lot of sense
that there would be a scholar here for
the first of the scholars as you may
recall is said to have doubted the
linking of the fire and was also a
private mentor to the Royal Prince
at the highest peaks of lothric Castle
are the grand archives home to the
scholars they're the faction with a
close relationship to the previous King
Osiris who went mad studying their store
of knowledge and this close relationship
between the crown and the scholars has
clearly carried over to the new Young
Prince lothric but who was the first
scholar there are many candidates but
many have theorized that it was oldia
and while all the evidence behind it
being oldia is circumstantial the rise
of the unkindled is certainly something
aldia would have fought for a destiny
beyond the scope of light beyond the
reach of dark a painted world inhabited
by Ash a future born of this world but
free of its curses
no small way the princes are responsible
for the rise of Ash and unintended
consequence of their grand betrayal
think you can kill me in PvP well this
is your chance in exactly two weeks on
the 23rd of September at 7 pm PDT I'll
be hosting a PVP event at the Kiln of
the first flame Arena if you invade me
and if you defeat me our first five
winners will each receive a gorgeous
limited edition copy of Dark Souls the
vinyl Trilogy which will be officially
released later this year our next 10
winners will receive a physical copy of
Dark Souls Beyond the Grave by Third
editions which is this comprehensive
well-written exploration of the entire
game law and all here are the
instructions this event will take place
on PC PS4 and Xbox One and while I'll
personally be fighting on PC you're
still eligible to win prizes if you
defeat one of my Champions that I'm
going to send to fight on my behalf on
Xbox One and PS4 so to compete you just
have to get everything you need to enter
the arena so acquire the Champion's bone
from ariandel burned them at Firelink
bonfire and then joined the undead match
just like I'm doing on screen
select dual at the Kiln of the first
flame with the password Discord or
lowercase in my name during the fight
won't be varti video you won't know that
you fought me unless you defeat me and I
message you afterwards on Discord and to
be eligible for these prizes you have to
be a part of our Discord server because
that's how I'm going to message you
click the link below and join and once
you're there change your Discord
nickname to the name of the character
that you'll be fighting with in the
arena this will just allow me to message
you in the unlikely event that you beat
me so again this two hour long event
takes place in exactly two weeks on the
23rd of September at 7 pm PDT you just
need to join the arena you need to join
my Discord you have to have the same
name as the character you're fighting
with on Discord so I can track you down
and yeah so in the description there's
everything I've said here there's the
Discord server link there's the rules
and there's a link to both of the
rewards if you just want to buy them
outright the there's a countdown timer
below there's a Time Zone Manager
everything you need and I'll also have a
video out in exactly two weeks on the
day that this event takes place just to
remind you one more time so I'll see you
then
[Music]